2013 sorgte amazon mit diesem video für
aufregung
kleine quadrocopter drohnen die
innerhalb von einer halben stunde unsere
produkte liefern können
das war natürlich genial doch obwohl wir
noch eine menge technischer und
rechtlicher fragen zu klären haben ist
amazon vision der zukunft immer noch
relativ klein gedacht
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge what's on genauso wie unsere
heutigen smartphones eigentlich nichts
mehr mit dem allerersten mobiltelefon
von 1983 zu tun haben
so haben auf unsere patschen plastik
drohen die im moment eigentlich nichts
mehr als spielzeug sind ein
riesenpotenzial
stellt euch eine stadt vor in der so
viele drohnen gibt wie autos und in der
drohnen quasi wie auf straßen fliegen
die möglichkeiten für den einsatzbereich
solcher drohnen sind beinahe endlos da
gibt es natürlich die lieferung von
denen wir gerade schon gesprochen hatten
die mir meine amazon pakete liefern oder
zum beispiel eine pizza die noch heiß
ist mal ganz nebenbei tvo - arbeitet
gerade in england an genau diesem
projekt jetzt dann gibt es natürlich
auch die etwas sinnvolleren erste hilfe
drohen die wesentlich schneller an einem
unfallort sein können als zum beispiel
notärzte gerade bei schlaganfällen oder
bei herzinfarkten kann das wirklich
leben retten
dann gibt's natürlich noch die security
drohnen könnten zum beispiel der polizei
helfen bei ausschreitungen oder bei
ähnlichen vorfällen nicht den überblick
zu verlieren oder sie könnten zum
beispiel auf straßen unfallorte mit
schildern absichern und das
nachrichtensender scharf auf diese
drohnen sind erklärt sich glaube ich von
alleine
die drohnen sind nicht nur viel billiger
als echte nachrichten helikopter mit
großen kameras die sind einfach viel
schneller einsatzbereit
ich denke mal so wie ich werden jetzt
die alle am meisten von euch sagen oh
mein gott bitte nicht tausende suchende
drohen über meinem kopf die nicht nur
mega nerven sondern auch welche die mich
beobachten können mit kameras und mit
allen möglichen die frage ist nicht ob
es technisch möglich ist denn das ist es
auf jeden fall unglaublich viele leute
sitzen jetzt gerade an ihren prototypen
werkeln daran rum und es ist nur eine
frage der zeit bis diese drohnen
wirklich marktreif sind und besser
funktionieren als sie es heute tun
die wichtige frage ist können wir diese
drohen schnell genug regulieren wie so
oft bewegt sich der technische
fortschritt viel schneller als die
gesetzgebung hinterher kommen kann
im januar 2015 zum beispiel ist eine
drohne auf dem grundstück vom weißen
haus in amerika bruch gelandet und
obwohl obama zu dem zeitpunkt nicht im
haus war und sich das ganze später als
unfall heraus
bleibt trotzdem noch einen komischen
nachgeschmack oder es ist eigentlich nur
eine frage der zeit bis jemand
herausfindet wie einfach es ist damit
über alles und jeden hinwegzufliegen
übrigens die aktuellen drohen haben
immer noch ein bisschen spielraum für
zusätzliches gewicht die angst vor dem
terror erreicht wieder ein neues level
und selbst wenn wir nicht von purer
gewalt sprechen finde ich es immer noch
ziemlich beängstigend dass quasi jeder
an diese drohnen herankommen kann das
neue modell von dj dem marktführer was
drogen angeht hat eine 4k kamera abwehr
das ist nicht nur eine unglaublich hohe
auflösung mit der man quasi alles filmen
kann
es ist in amerika nicht mal illegal wenn
ich mich vor dein privates haus stelle
und in dein fenster rein filme was wo
bleibt denn da die privatsphäre und bei
den heutigen standards wäre es nicht mal
unmöglich so was direkt zu live stream
ich habe also keine möglichkeit mich in
irgendeiner art und weise zu schützen
und genau das hat finde ich und so
nervig das doch ist für jeden der damit
eigentlich nichts böses anfangen will
sollte man anfangen drohnen
führerscheine einzuführen damit die
leute informiert und getestet werden
bevor sie sich so eine drohne überhaupt
anschaffen können und außerdem bin ich
der meinung dass die amazon drohnen oder
irgendeine drohnen überhaupt nicht die
möglichkeit haben sollte das gefilmte
material für irgendetwas anderes zu
benutzen als um sich zu orientieren und
nirgendwo gegen zu fliegen obwohl die
nsa da wahrscheinlich anderer meinung
ist ich habe ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
angst vor den drogen der zukunft und
abgesehen von dieser erste hilfe drohne
die wirklich leben retten kann sehe ich
da keinen so riesigen mehrwert für die
gesellschaft
ich meine da krieg ich halt mein amazon
paket morgen oder übermorgen stadt in
den nächsten 30 minuten
dafür steht unsere sicherheit und unsere
privatsphäre auf dem spiel
ich selber überlege mir gerade ob ich so
eine drohne kaufe um zum beispiel meine
kurzfilme zu verbessern weil man da
kriegt man halt cool aufnahmen und so
aber trotzdem wäre mir ein präventives
verbot von allen drohen lieber als das
ganze unreguliert zulassen
was meint ihr quadrocopter drohen in der
stadt ja oder nein oder nur spezielle
drohen mit einer speziellen genehmigung
schreibt mir auf jeden fall unten denen
die kommentare ich bin sehr gespannt auf
eure meinung und wird sehr gerne mit
euch darüber diskutieren ansonsten wenn
euch die zukunft mit drohnen
interessiert kann ich euch dieses
hörbuch hier oben empfehlen drohnen land
das könnt ihr kostenlos bekommen wenn
ihr euch bei audible einen probe account
erstellt den link dazu findet ihr unten
in der video beschreibung ansonsten
kommt ihr hier noch zu den
an beiden videos meiner serie und ich
sage erst mal vielen dank fürs zuschauen
bis zum nächsten mal
und bis zum nächsten donnerstag um 19
uhr chargers